well quite a day today very exciting as
the padres make many additions fernando
tatis jr now steps in from the right
side
oh two pitch swang and a miss he got him
with a slider
back back-to-back strikeouts to start
the night for airmen
garrett richards on the mound tonight
for the friars well as a big league
pitcher as any pitcher you have to
forget about your previous outings and
garrett starts his eighth this season
and i think the big key down is quick
early innings he's thrown a lot of
pitches the last couple times out last
time out only two thirds prior to that
two winnings
and there is nola we just saw him he was
just in town with the seattle mariners
and now a member of the padres grisham
is
interestingly a few steps towards right
center out there in center field nolan
swings and misses at another slider and
that's strike three and the inning comes
to an end here comes mitch moreland for
the first time in a padres uniform fired
on sunday from boston
on the ground right side slowly hit
mcmahon will go to second for one that's
all they'll get it's arnado in the shift
who covered the bag at second base so
that will go four to five
the rookie had a big day yesterday three
more hits including a homer one two
pitch coming to the rookie cronin worth
did he go too far he did that strike
three on the curve ball irmond with a
pair of punch-outs in each of the first
two winnings charlie trying to regain
the mojo he had early in the season
pitch to charlie lined into right center
field for a base hit that's how you beat
the shift rockies get their first hit of
the night a
lead off base hit just like the padres
had in their half of the second
first played appearance here in a padres
uniform 306 this year with the mariners
and a ground ball up the middle and by
the dive a trevor story to left center
field austin nola has got a base hitting
his first padres at bat board to begin
things here in the third inning one out
runners at the corner still a nothing
nothing game and here's the ever
dangerous fernando tatis jr
this one is lying to left center field
that ball is going to get in and by the
dive of hilliard coming around to score
will be nola pro far from first base
will be waved around he will come in and
score as tati sends up at third with a
two-run triple and the padres take a
two-nothing lead in denver tonight do
you hear the drums fernando
i'll bet you do
tatis is now in third base with one out
padres jump out of the two-nothing
advantage and annie machado
this one is in the air to center field
back goes hillyard and he'll make the
catch tagging easily from third is tatis
he will score and the padres take a
three-nothing lead nice easy swing from
manny
marquez back on the mount here to deal
with will myers
oh this one is drilled to straight away
center field hillyard is back at the
wall and pulls into the woods into the
forest home run for will myers his ninth
of the year and the padres take a four
nothing lead well myers loves coors
field just adds on to his amazing
numbers there
oh the sound of this one you know looked
like a changeup out of the hand of
marquez he stays on it nicely and rides
it out
here's the 1-0 and cronenworth hits that
one sharply down the right field line
that's a fair ball underneath of daniel
murphy into the corner groninworth is
digging for second blackman just getting
to the ball and now chronoworth is on
his way to third he'll make it without a
throw
jake cronenworth with his third triple
of the season and the second of the
night for the padres marquez had 62
pitches here in the fourth he cruised
right through the first two innings
padres sent seven men to the plate in
the third and scored three times they've
added a run here in the fourth and
threatening for much more
this one is chopped back of the mound
coming in to score from third is
kronerworth and the throw in and out of
the glove of murphy
at first base ronald score padres lead
at five nothing cronenworth in the back
door from third austin nola the newly
acquired catcher has been active
he'll bounce this one up the third
baseline nolan grabs it jump throw to
first and got him my oh my
bounding ball down the third base side
nolan grabbed it went into foul ground
made the jump throw and got him one two
he was out by two steps
that's why this kid has won a platinum
glove
rawlings platinum glove not a gold glove
he's got that too but the best of the
best
so two down and a runner at first for
eric hosmer the dh payoff pitch and this
one is in the air to right field down
the line out there and making go did not
make the catches mcmahon off the glove
and tatis is coming around to score
throw to second not in time hosmer into
second of the padres tack on another run
welcome
trevor rosenthal to the san diego padres
welcome to san diego 30 year old right
hander
and it's picked by rosenthal the toss to
first for out number one
blackman retired on a hot shot return to
sender one down hockey suit glove saving
a beauty
two down murphy at first and ryan
mcmahon
he struck him out in the padres win
trevor rosenthal in his first appearance
in a padres uniform works the ninth and
finishes the game as the padres complete
the shutout a six-nothing win for san
diego over the colorado rockies